Abby Lee Miller shows off her incredible
weight loss from inside prison on Friday
a source told ET exclusively the former
Dance Moms star had dropped 100 pounds
since entering prison and on Sunday
Miller shared the results on Instagram
that's Miller in the center wearing her
prison uniform rocking a dramatically
slimmer physique the 51 year old reality
star appeared in good spirits as she
posed for a photo with a small group of
visitors she reflected on her life in a
lengthy caption after apologizing for
her mistakes Miller wrote in part quote
my world flipped upside down when I had
to enter prison I have made friends with
both inmates and staff I've tried to
better myself participated in anything
offered to me and I am a better person
for this experience Miller is currently
serving a 1 year and 1 day sentence at
the Federal Correctional Complex in
Victorville California after she pled
guilty to bankruptcy fraud in June 2016
the source told ET on Friday Miller will
be released on February 20th are you
concerned about keeping the weight off
in prison no I'll just concentrate on
and that's different I've always put
everybody else's child first before my
own health you'll remember the dance
instructor underwent gastric bypass
surgery just before her sentencing
people are saying but your sentencing is
coming up in a couple weeks and this the
other thing and that is true and I'm
really nervous about that more than the
surgery but there's no right time the
source says Abby is feeling great and
has already requested multiple surgeries
for when she's released including a
tummy tuck breast lifts and excess skin
removal
[Music]